germany has recorded more than 50 000
coronavirus deaths since the start of
the pandemic
that number has risen sharply over
recent weeks even as
infection figures are finally declining
hundreds of deaths
sometimes more than one thousand have
been reported daily across germany over
recent weeks
in some parts of the country intensive
care units and crematoriums have reached
their limit
the situation has prompted the german
government to once again extend the
country's lockdown
a germany's health minister yen span has
been giving an update alongside health
officials he says
the coronavirus case numbers are
encouraging but still too high
the vaccination program is giving us
hope in the current situation
the crisis is at its peak but we are
beginning to leave the pandemic behind
us
i'll step under me begone you feel
that this is not happening quickly
enough i would also like to have more
vaccine doses available
so that more people can be immunised
let's bring in our correspondent jared
reed who's following the latest on the
story for us hi
jared we mentioned that grim number 50
000 deaths here in germany
bring us up to speed on the situation
that's right sumi very sadly 50 000 over
50 000 people have now died from
or or of covert 19 in germany there have
been around 2.1
million cases so far but there is
encouraging news in so far as that
infection rates
are on a steady decline as they stand
today
the infection rate is 115 per
100 000 of population over a seven day
period as i say that number has been
uh steadily declining but uh not
fast enough which is why uh the
government and the states agreed earlier
this week to
extend current restrictions until
february
the 14th this shuts down continues to
shut down
large parts of public life like schools
and day cares
shops as well and they are encouraging
more
medical mask wearing and there is going
to be an obligation on
employers to make sure that more of
their employees
work from home so that the infection
risk in offices
is reduced and also on public transport
the big worry at the moment
is these mutations that are starting to
be seen in germany there have been
isolated cases of them
and health authorities really want don't
want these mutations to become
dominant here well those health
authorities have been speaking to
journalists today
tell us more about what they've been
saying
that's right we've just been hearing
from lotto villa who's the head of the
robert koch institute which is germany's
infectious diseases
body he has been saying that there are
16 000
nursing homes in germany and currently
of those 16
900 are experiencing quite serious
uh covert 19 outbreaks and he's saying
the ones that are doing better are the
ones that uh
have the resources and expertise to to
manage the situation and he
he hopes that those that aren't managing
it so well will get the resources like
staffing
that uh they need he's saying that
people over 80 continue to be a
significant
risk group here in germany too and jared
how are germans taking all of this the
extended restrictions
largely they're supportive a recent
polling shows that around 40 percent
of people surveyed here in germany were
for
significant um significant hardening of
restrictions around 20 wanted them to
stay as they are but by and large
consistently over the last few months
we've seen
that public support for restrictions
here
is has been consistently high
our political correspondent jared reed
thank you
now the number of new cases in england
has dropped from a peak of nearly 70 000
per day in the first week of january
to just under forty thousand on thursday
but the uk has recorded more
deaths per capita than any other country
in the world and the number continues to
rise
hospitals up and down the country are
being stretched to their limits
and we want to warn our viewers you
might find some of these images
disturbing
this woman in her mid-20s is fighting
for survival
intensive care units have reached their
limit the doctors are volunteers from
other units of this london hospital
they breathe a sigh of relief the
patient is stable for now
she's young she's someone's relative
this
is something precious that we're holding
and we're trying to do
yeah it's quite frightening 12 of the
hospital's 15 floors are
filled with corona patients doctors
tried desperately to find beds for new
admissions
he's got he's got covered and he's had a
stroke
one bed has become available up until an
hour ago
hannah freeborn lay in it she was a
mother a grandmother
and just 64. i won't wish this on
anybody
this this really is horrible it's real
the corona mutation from the south of
england is clearly more contagious
a strict lockdown since the start of
january has done little to reduce the
number
of new infections
we've got to observe the the lockdown
the stay-at-home
message that's absolutely crucial in the
in what is
unquestionably going to be a tough few
weeks ahead
the flood of patients is not expected to
ease and the death toll remains high
the result of a coronavirus mutation
that is out of control
let's go to london now our correspondent
berget moss is standing by for us there
hi burkett
how bad is the situation right now in
the uk
it's pretty bad almost 100 000 people
100 000 people have died because of the
virus and
as it was explained in the report many
hospitals don't know
where to put the patients they're really
running out of beds and
the problem is the new variant of the
coronavirus which is
quite prevalent in london and the south
east but
it has also been traveling across the
country
and this new strain is is very difficult
for the authorities to get under control
and
and people that i know that are
vulnerable are quite frightened
frightened i have one friend who was
always very pragmatic she's vulnerable
but now she's really shielding
completely so
people are taking this very very
seriously
and the government the environment
minister now says that the government is
considering a full
closure of borders what can you tell us
about that
this is something that's being debated
in the uk i think the context is
actually
when the situation gets better in the uk
but we know that
other countries across the world might
be still struggling with new variants so
in the uk what has been successful is
the vaccination program over seven
percent of the population have now
received at least one dose
of one of the vaccines so that is um in
the international comparison is really
quite high particularly in the european
context
and now the government are thinking of
how to protect
their own country so once the uk
has gotten this virus better under
control
but in other countries there might be
new variants
how how can they protect the uk so it's
being discussed
possibly to have um government
accommodation
for for travelers that are coming into
the uk or electronic tagging or
um more closing of the borders and and
tougher border restrictions so all this
is being debated at the moment
and you know you said the situation is
pretty bad the virus is spreading
hospitals are overwhelmed
how are people in london coping right
now
well people are definitely scared so
when i
walk um through the streets of london
the streets are pretty empty you don't
see
a lot of people congregating and most
people know some
no other people who have had uh kovid
um obviously a lot of people have it and
and then they get better but you know
some people know people who have died so
it is very real it's a it's a very real
threat
now there is light at the end of the
tunnel with a new
with a vaccination so i think people are
just
you know hoping for the best that uh
within a few
months really that the situation will be
better but definitely
the next weeks are going to be tough
because the hospitals are so over
overwhelmed and and that is not going to
change anytime soon
very good mass for us in london thank
you
the rate of new infections in israel
remains high as the country battles a
third wave of infections
but at the same time israel is
vaccinating people
faster than anywhere else the government
says all
israeli citizens will be inoculated by
the end of march
israel was able to move fast after
securing a special but also
controversial deal with the vaccine
manufacturer
biotech pfizer
this basketball stadium in tel aviv is
now a vaccination center
people under the age of 35 are already
being immunized here
while older residents are getting their
second jab
the vaccines are being administered in
record time
bayern tech pfizer is delivering
millions of doses
in return the pharma companies are
receiving valuable data
that allows them to measure the efficacy
of their product
i don't have a problem with the data
agreement and i don't feel like i'm part
of an experiment
we're leading the world on vaccinations
and israel offers the right kind of
infrastructure
it's israel's health care system with
its universal insurance
that makes the country so interesting to
buy and tech pfizer
insurance companies allocate doctors to
patients streamlining the vaccination
program
the digitalized and centralized nature
of data collection
has created a treasure trove of readily
available information
if one wants to understand how a real
world
rollout of a vaccine program impacts
public health
than israel with its digital health
repositories
and its very strong methodological
capabilities
and it's a very good outreach of
public health and clinical health to all
of the citizens
is probably an ideal place to do that
the main objective is to find out at
what stage the vaccination drive
achieves herd immunity
and to figure out ways to get there fast
the data used in the research has been
made anonymous
but that hasn't stopped critics from
sounding the alarm
people are saying what's the problem
with anonymized data and the problem is
that anonymized data medical data today
can be uh transferred to be
non-anonymized if you have the right
tools and the right technology
we want to have a kind of an oversight
experts that will
make sure that this data is not going to
be exploited later by third parties
prime minister benjamin netanyahu has
emphasized
that the findings will benefit the rest
of the world
but his prime focus is the impact that
the vaccination program is having in
israel itself
[Music]
we will be the first country to defeat
the pandemic
the deal i have struck with pfizer
allows us to vaccinate everyone above 16
by the end of march
the ambitious target coincides with
parliamentary elections
which netanyahu is hoping to win but
while the number of vaccinations are
shooting up
so too are infections a race against
time that israel is determined to win
you